[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chest
website comm and today we're gonna be
starting a new series and we're gonna be
covering famous chest wraps and I think
this will be fun
I enjoyed chest wraps and I think people
can learn from them and at the same time
make sure that they do not fall into any
of the traps that we're going to go over
so the first trap we're gonna be going
over today is the kind injure trap and
it derives from the Budapest gambit
which is a gambit from black which you
don't often see since gambits are
usually from the white side but it
starts off with pawn to d4 responded by
black developing to Knight f6 and why
it's gonna continue pawn to c4 and
blacks going to offer up his pawn on e5
and this is the Budapest game that we
were talking about and white simply
going to capture the pawn on e5 and
blacks going to continue with Knight to
g4 and we are attacking this pawn on e5
now white has two options he can just
give up the pawn on e5 and give up pawn
advantage or you can try to hold on to
it and the trap is going to stem from
the line if white tries to hold on to
the extra pawn that he has so from here
White's going to add a defender to this
pawn with Bishop to f4 as you can see it
has black has one attacker and white has
one defendant and so blacks going to
continue his assault on the e5 pawn
developing his knight to c6 and adding
another attacker and White's going to
continue
Knight to f3 developing his Knight and
at the same time adding an extra
defender to the e5 pawn and from here
white once or excuse me black wants to
bring his Queen to e7 but he wants to
get his Bishop out first you obviously
don't want to block your Bishop so
blacks first move is going to be Bishop
to b4 check and from here you often see
Knight to d2 kind of setting up a trap
in itself and from here black is going
to continue with Queen to e7 obviously
as you can see now we have three
attackers on the e5 pawn and white only
has two defenders so White's going to
have to choose a different strategy and
from here a lot of times you'll see pawn
to e3 basically he's attacking the
bishop and trying to kick that out here
and from here black can actually safely
take on e5 obviously white if they
capture this Knight they have two
attackers and black has two defenders so
they can easily hold on to this pawn
that they captured and here is the trap
and so many players will fall for it if
they are not looking and that's simply a
captures Bishop on b4 and from here you
can probably see it black can come in
to d3 unexpectedly and checkmate so
anytime you do play the budapest gamete
if you're black then look out for this
if white tries to hold on to their pawn
on e5 and you see this then make them
pay so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
there's gonna be tons more videos on
damage traps coming out so if you
haven't already subscribed please go
ahead and do that and I'll see you guys
next video thanks for watching